everyone this is kevin from the chess
website com2 they're going to be going
over game 2 from the World Chess
Championships being played by Anne on
the current world champion and magnus
carlsen the Challenger the highest rated
player in the world right now and so
Game one
if you watch that video was a draw it
was a very short game it was only 16
moves and it had threefold repetition so
there's only actually about 14 moves in
chess so going into Game two White's now
going to be played by an on Magnus
Carlsen play the white pieces in the
first game and then in this particular
game blacks going to be defended by
Magnus Carlsen so it starts out with
pawn to e4 and this is pretty common for
non likes to play you know this efore
he's had a lot of success with it
obviously and you know it was kind of
curious to see where Magnus Carlsen was
going to go and he decided to go for the
Cara con so playing this c6 kind of
signifying what his opening is going to
be and so we see you know pawn to d4
this is pretty common pawn pushing
forward to d5 you know this is the car
con looking to get his blight squared
Bishop involved into the action before
he kind of blocks off that pawn chain
here with pawn to e6 and then gets his
dark squared bishop involved into the
game which is exactly what we see in
this game we now see Knight here to c3
and then the pawn takes the knight
recaptures there on e4 and then this
light square bishop gets involved into
the game here coming here to f5 putting
pressure on this night the Knights just
going to swing back here to g3 attacking
his bishop and the bishop just going to
swing back here to g6 and now the pawn
starts pushing forward to h4 on the
Kings side from anon so recognizing
early on he wants to start putting some
pressure trying to play this pawn to h5
kind of trapping this bishop here on g6
also kind of signifying that White's
probably going to cast on the Queen side
he's starting to really push forward on
the King side you usually don't want to
castle on the Kings side if you have a
choice if you do kind of have all this
air between you know your pawns and the
protected King over here so again this
is kind of a telling move right away
that you know why it's going to start
putting some pressure on this Kings side
and so from here we see pawn to h6 just
making sure there's a little scapegoat a
little
right here on h7 that this light squared
bishop can get to white now plays Knight
to f3 again you usually want to get your
Knights involved into the action very
early on again also this is a very great
square for this knight protecting this
pawn here on d4 and also just attacking
the center of the board now we see pawn
to e6 it is pretty common actually to
see Knight to d7 right here kind of
blocking off the Knight to e5 right away
instead we see this pawn to e6 and then
an on played Knight to e5 and there was
you know people were kind of curious how
nan would actually play in this
particular case and one of his people
that he uses they call them seconds it's
actually kind of their their entourage
if you will LICO actually plays this
Knight to e5 and so you know with all
the hours and hours and days and months
of preparation you definitely know that
some of this may have come in where Lika
was kind of telling anon hey you know
this Knight to e5 is pretty powerful
because you know it kind of forces back
this Bishop here to h7 and now when this
Bishop comes to d3 and there's an
exchange White's kind of got some some
time in there whereas you know if we see
right away instead of the knight coming
here to e5 let's say we had the bishop
coming here to d3 first and now the
bishop takes now the Queen can come here
to d3 but why it's kind of a loss to
move here so it's blacks move now but
this Knight is no longer here on e5 so
because of these slight variations and
how white moves white actually kind of
gets a little bit better of a position
by playing that Knight to e5 first and
so that's what actually happens in the
game we see the pawn coming here to e6
and then pawn to e5 forcing this Bishop
back and now the bishops going to come
here to b3 and there's going to be an
exchange right here in the Queen's come
and takes on d3 magnus carlsen now
played the Knight to d7 again worked in
moves into the game and if you look at
it you say okay both sides seem like
they're prepared Magnus Carlsen had used
about a minute of his time by this
particular case so you know although we
may look at and say you know this
preparation is good an on looks like he
knows
activities doing magnus carlsen wasn't
even thinking or blinking when he was
moving he was rapid-fire he knew exactly
what to expect he was definitely
prepared for the specific opening from
anon so definitely looked like both
sides knew what they were doing both
people looked pretty confident if you
actually got to see the live commentary
and so we continue with pawn to f4 again
already we know that white wants to
castle on the Queen side so starting to
go ahead and put pressure on this King
side also putting you know another
defender on this square on e5 and now we
have the bishop coming to be four this
is kind of twofold one it's kind of
baiting a you know white to see okay is
the bishop going to come here to d2 is
the paw going to push forward a little
bit there's that's really the only
options that white had right here white
you know black really just wants to test
the waters and then he's gonna bring you
know his bishop back get is not involved
into the game and then castle more than
likely on the Kings side but could
always castle on the Queen side as well
again white starting to put some
pressure on the King side so it could be
kind of dangerous if he decides to
castle on the Kings side the pot is not
going to come to c3 kind of what we all
expected and then the bishop just falls
back here to e7 now the bishop comes
here to d2 and this was kind of an
interesting move you know white could
have always tried something a little bit
more aggressive could have tried this
you know Knight to h5 you can sometimes
take advantage of your opponent if he
hasn't brought both of his knights into
the game so in this particular case you
know this pawn here on d7 is under
attack now Magnus Carlsen would never
fall for something like this but you
know if you're trying to think of
different ways in your own game you can
start to attack this can get pretty
dangerous for your opponent you know
let's say this pawn pushes forward to g6
you know this Knight can now take here
on g6 and then after takes we have the
Queen come and then after the King
swings over this is going to be a free
rook right here again not something that
Carlson can is really going to fall into
especially since he hasn't used any of
his time so he would have plenty of time
to to not fall for that
but again just something to if white
really wanted to add a lot of pressure
he could play this you know h5
really doesn't put him in a bad spot by
any means we could really start to put
the pressure on Carlson and really have
him you know figure out what he wants to
do is he want to move his bishop begins
and he's already moved it a couple times
but white decide to go ahead and play
for more of a safer route this Bishop
here to d2 it's not really forcing the
action but does allow for white to go
ahead and castle on the Queen side very
very quickly now we have black bringing
his knight to f6 magnus carlsen
definitely wants to get some King safety
also recognizing that he needs to get
his other Knight involved into the game
and that we have castle and it was kind
of interesting to see you know which
side magnus carlsen wants to castle if
you once cast on the Queen side
obviously he wants to go ahead he's
gonna need to get his queen involved
into the game you know c7 here b6 if you
wanted to castle on the Queen side if
you Castle on the Kings side you know
that kind of opens up some fireworks
potentially with both sides castling on
both of the opposite sides and why it's
already putting a lot of pressure on the
King side so that could be a little bit
dangerous Magnus Carlsen plays dangerous
and he decides to go ahead and castle on
the Kings side so again in the game this
was definitely one of those points where
we were expecting some fireworks it was
looking pretty crazy now we see Knight
to e4 and this is where magnus carlsen
for the first time in the entire match
actually took quite a bit of time and I
say quite a bit time he took 10 minutes
may take more time on this particular
move then he had by far the rest of the
match combined and so we see up into
this point so we see Knight to e4 and
magnus carlsen decides to go ahead and
recapture and then after the Queen
recaptures Magnus Carlsen decides to
give up more material and then the pawn
retakes right here why could have retake
in with a few different options but I do
like the pawn taking here it does you
know provide provides some additional
defense to this pawn on h4 we now have
the Queen here and the rook here both
protecting this pawn you know black does
have this bishop it is queen both eyeing
down on this pawn on h4 and also you
know it kind of blocks off you know this
entire thing right here and it really
just opens up all these free lanes to
white to go ahead to attack on this King
side
in this queen side right now somewhat
safe this bishops going to have a hard
time really maneuvering around all of
these squares that this Bishop would
like to go to we're kind of blocked off
because these pawns right here so you
know things were definitely looking good
for white Magnus Carlsen decided to come
to d5 and everyone under the Sun really
expected white to come to g4 really has
all the momentum right here definitely
be a mistake
you know this pawns being attacked right
here on a2 but you know that definitely
losses to the bishop coming here to h6
you know one move checkmate even if you
know the pawn comes to h6 you know
something you know pawn to h5 is just
too much for black to deal with he's
going to end up losing a ton of material
and there's not much that this lone
Queen can do over here on a - yes he has
taken a pawn but that's pretty much all
he's going to be able to do that there
are some other options that you know
black has could always try King over
here to AJ it's making it safe obviously
if you have you know kind of a pin you
want to get that that King out of the
way could always try something a little
bit more aggressive could try this pawn
to f5 if you wanted to that could really
open things up more than it was before
but more than likely you kind of have to
play this Queen to g4 you're the white
pieces you have the advantage right now
in the game the King side is completely
open for you to start attacking or
chipping away out at least you can start
to even push some of your other pawns up
the board but this kind of keeps you
alive in the game if you don't have your
queen you're pretty much just laying
down unfortunately for the chess
community you know nan took quite a bit
the time on this move and then I think
he just didn't like where it was going
and decided to instead just take with
his queen here on d5 and just pretty
much exchange which really just leads to
the end of the game with so many pawns
it's a close game so these bishops
aren't going to be doing too much
there's also no lanes or files or
anywhere for these rooks to really get
involved no one's going to do any crazy
sacrifice especially so close to the end
game and so from here both sides just
kind of played it
out a little bit nothing too crazy and
then we see a three-fold repetition like
we did in the first game and after 25
moves the players shook hands and it was
a drawl so started out in my opinion
very exciting a lot more exciting than
Game one but as we kind of moved into
the later stage of the game it
definitely looked like Magnus Carlsen
was completely okay with a drawl
especially with the black pieces and a
non just didn't want to fight for the
small advantage that he did have so game
2 was a drawl it had some exciting
points it ended not as exciting as we
would have liked but again these guys
they have one thing in mind and that is
to at least be if you're not at least
tied or 1/2 point a head and Magnus
Carlsen he just wants to be a half point
at the end of this he doesn't really
care if the games are super exciting or
not so again all in all game 2 hopefully
you guys enjoyed and I'll see you on the
next one thanks for watching